Corea del Norte lanzó hoy un misil
balístico intercontinental o icbm por
primera vez desde 2017 el proyectil que
ha aterrizado unos 150 kilómetros al
oeste de La Isla japonesa dejó caído
voló unos 1.100 kilómetros y alcanzó una
altura máxima de unos 6.200 esto implica
que se trataría de un icbm lanzado en un
ángulo muy abierto y que probablemente
se trataría del llamado juanson 17 un
nuevo misil intercontinental norcoreano
que se cree que tiene un alcance de unos
15.000 kilómetros suficiente para
golpear a Nueva York o Washington desde
pyongyang este lanzamiento de hoy
también implica que Corea del Norte da
por rota la moratoria que según tu
impuso de Cara a los lanzamientos de
icbm en 2018 para tratar de alcanzar un
acercamiento justo antes de las cumbres
que celebraron el líder norcoreano Kim
Jong entonces presidente estadounidense
Donald Trump sin embargo con el con
Estados Unidos roto desde 2019 y con el
país completamente aislado aún por la
pandemia el régimen norcoreano decidió
el año pasado a probar un plan de
modernización de armas que parece estar
cumpliendo a raja tabla y que apunta
también a la posibilidad de que en un
futuro próximo vuelva a realizar una
prueba nuclear algo que Corea del Norte
No hace desde hace cinco años